Kaleigh happy one-year wedding
anniversary yeah I mean everybody loves
you and Carl you the question that we
were getting is Carla did post them like
kind of candid photos of you oh did you
were you okay with that
well he doesn't ask me before he post
them so he just he loves a good sleeping
picture
no no not Sleeping Beauty like oh he
loves like a real yes and he loves it
taken who loves a picture from here not
good no and he'll be like he'll do this
first year of marriage and now favorite
thing to do
he's just funny but year six he'll know
not to do yeah yeah I'm just like yep
right now it's kind of cute but there's
no pre-approval process no oh no he's
like he's his own man he makes his own
Instagram decisions wowzers he's bold
but how is it going this first year
how's it feeling for you guys is it
still newlywed phase yeah we're the best
I know I didn't marry him so he's the
best other than our obviously Instagram
feud we're doing really kaley cuoco also
opened up about another good thing when
et set Dan with her what I can't wait
for you guys to see my new show her new
r-rated animated series from the DC
Universe Harley Quinn featuring Lake
Bell with Harley Quinn I mean you guys
are how dirty does it really get we
talked f-bombs beyond that dirty dirty
honestly good dirty we weren't really
together but progressive yes great
resentment of it and love that yes it's
very that has to feel amazing you know
you're getting an apartment it doesn't
matter when I read the script but were
you just like yes
you